quand je vois des jeunes gens et qui me
regardent ils me trouvent vieille mais
moi je me trouve jeune c'est justement
ça le
drame le carnaval de Nice s'est terminé
avanthier
[Musique]
soir
pendant que les fanfares et les
majorettes défilai sur la promenade des
anglais nous sommes nous entrés dans la
ville ici au marché à la recherche de
ces vieux pour qui Nice a toujours été
une fascination celle de la retraite au
[Musique]
soleil
la retraite au soleil certains la
trouvent d'autres
non comment est-ce que vous avez fait
pour vous loger à
Nice c'est
par j'ai j'ai mis 5 ans pour trouver
cela
et c'est par quelqu'un que je
connaissais quelqu'un qui avait cette
pièce qui me l'a
céd part vous êtes en souslocation ah
non non je suis en en location
régulière mais cette pièce c'est quoi
exactement euh c'est une c'est un
sous-sol c'est un sous-sol une cave si
vous aimez
mieux c'est ce que vous pensiez trouver
àce ah ah non non moi je pensais trouver
un endroit ensoleillé clair et
ensoleillé mais ici je vis sous
terre alors ce n'est pas une solution
pour ma
santé combien est-ce que vous payz pour
cette C 12000 francs par mois 12000
anciens francs et quels sont vos
revenus une pension d'un pension
d'incapacité 45000 francs par
trimestre et une une allocation
loyer comment est-ce que vous faites
alors pour
vivre je m'arrange avec
[Musique]
ça je
ne je n'ai pas les je je n'ai pas
énormément d'appétit du du fait que je
suis malade
et alors pour l'instant ça va est-ce
qu'elle n'a pas un peu honte de vous
faire payer les loyer qu'elle vous
demande pour que vous habitiez une
cave je ne pense pas parce que les les
loyers sont devenus libres et ces prixl
sont autorisés actuellement n'est-ce pas
et malgré
tout c'est chauffé par des
tuyaux alors
c'est ça serait intenable si n'était pas
chauffé mais il y a des personnes à Nice
qui vivent dans des caves non
chauffées alors là je me demande comment
elle
font est-ce que vous racontez à votre
propriétaire les inconvénients qu'il y a
à habiter ici ah non parce qu'elle le
prendrait très mal qu'est-ce que vous
entendez par elle le prendrait très mal
elle vous mettrait dehors très
certainement c'est ce qui a failli se
produire comment est-ce que vous faites
pour garder cette cave si bien tenue et
si
propre parce que c'est c'est ma nature
d'être propre et je et on ne change pas
sa
nature je crois que on est propre ou
sale et on reste propre jusqu'à la
fin quand vous étiez jeune c'est c'est
c'est fatigant c'est fatigant pour moi
mais je le
fais quand vous étiez jeune et que vous
pensiez à la vieillesse vous voyez ce
que vous faites maintenant qu'est-ce que
vous envisangz ah non non je
ne je crois que si on m'avait fait voir
ce que j'endurerai ici les souffrances
que j'ai enduré ici particulièrement et
depuis la fin de la guerre je crois que
je je me serai
tué et voilà vous avez des contacts avec
le monde
extérieur euh ici à
pas vous ne le voulez
pas je connais
personne je connaissais des personnes
âgées qui sont mortes depuis de vieilles
amis et vous n'avez pas eu la
possibilité de nouer des relations
nouvelles non parce que
je n'ai pas trouvé ici le le genre
de genre d'amis de relation que j'ai
l'habitude
d'avoir vous êtes seul dans la vie oui
Absolum depuis longtemps
oh oui
oui oui parce que ma famille était à
l'étranger
j'ai toujours vécu seul en
France vous souffrez de cette solitud ah
oui oui ce n'est pas
drôle
pour tu
attends la nuit l'été
l'amour mais viendrontil en même
temps la nuit l'été l'amour
et qui sait si tu ne vas pas
regretter l'amour la nuit
l'été avant même qu'il soit venu dans ta
vie l'été l'amour la
nuit mais qu'importe après tout de
savoir si c'est la nuit ou bien l'été
lorsque l'amour est là on lui tente
alors les bras et il vous fait danser et
il vous fait chanter
on lui tente alors les bras et il vous
fait danser et il vous fait
chanter dans ton cœur longtemps
rester la nuit l'été
l'amour il sont dans toutes les
chansons la nuit
l'été c'est le seul endroit où
réellement on peut trouver à l'heure
actuelle du
soleil je le pense
toujours
c'est je suis resté en Normandie dans un
un pays qui est très chic en été très
agréable très beau très riche mais en
hiver froid et humide alors une fois la
retraite prise on Sange qu'il y a une
chose on se met à la chaleur au soleil
vous n'avez pas été déçu par la vie que
vous avez trouvé à Nice si c'est-à-dire
c'est le changement brutal
de passer d'une activité
assez assez grande parce que poste de
chef d'entretien dans une usine est un
poste absorbant et me trouver
subitement s sans emploi c'estàdire sans
activité aucune alors on est un peu
comment on dit débordé on s'ennuie un
peu au début et puis on se promène on a
voyagé nous avons fait tous les
alentours de Nice promenade mais depuis
10 ans les atau se fait maintenant nous
nous contentons de voyager dans l'ISS
même qui est une très jolie ville
d'ailleurs je souhaite tous les
retraités de pouvoir venir s'établir ici
à quoi vous occupez-vous dans la journée
beaucoup de mots croisés des mots
croisés le soir surtout l'après-midi
nous sortons c'est par un temps comme ça
vers 2h3 nous sortons nous rentrons
entre 5 et 6h et quelles sont les
occupations de votre femme et bien elle
s'occupe de faire beaucoup de ménage
elle fait le ménage elle-même elle fait
elle est très occupée tous les matins va
au marché fait la cuisine son ménage
puaprès-midi nous sortons le temps vous
paraît long non les semaines passent
avec une rapidité
extraordinaire très vite même je crois
que plus on vieillit plus il me semble
que les jours passent a une rapidité
extraordinaire vous ne vous ennuyez
jamais non c'est pas un ennui proprement
dit c'est changement n'est-ce pas il y a
des moments où il pleut par exemple tel
qu' hier ben on est un peu on s'ennuie
on sans s'ennuy parce qu'on on regarde
la télévision quand on ne sort pas le
dimanche après-midi B c'est la
[Musique]
télévision alors moi jeis rien moi et
ben tiens alors tu V les donner toi tu a
de
lait non non
non très bien très
bien alors
3 moi je continue à
J il faut rire il faut rire il faut pr
un faes pas belle faites pas très belle
oui oui surtout très
belle
[Musique]
la bon ça va à qui a
joué c'est à vous à jou
monsieur
est-ce qu'il y a des choses que vous
faisiez avant et que vous ne pouvez plus
faire l'âge venant oh mais vous me posez
une question je pense qu'il y a tout
même des choses que je ne pourrais plus
faire mais pas encore maintenant plus
tard si vous voulez
bien parce que vraiment je ne sais pas
maintenant évidemment quand je vois des
jeunes gens et qui me regardent il me
trouve vieille mais moi je me trouve
jeune c'est justement ça le drame non
pratiquement pas pourquoi un drame c'est
un drame bien oui je ne sais pas je
pense que vous qui êtes jeune que ça
vous arrivera aussi quand on se dit
tiens on monte en grain on monte en
âgeon il y a des choses que on voudrait
faire qu'on peut plus faire quoi par
exemple oh vous me demandez des
questions très bizarres parce que moi
j'ai toujours aimé l'action assez
violente les courses en voiture j'en ai
fait beaucoup maintenant on m'en prend
plus j'ai passé l'âge et y a même des
choses je pense que je ne pourrais plus
faire ce que j'ai fait
d'ailleurs vous pensez au
passé non
jamais j'estime que comme j'ai fait pas
mal d'années de concentration et bien le
jour qui passe est un jour de gagné dans
les vies et je le vis
aussi comme j'aimerais de le vivre le
plus gaiement possible et je ne compte
le passer c'est s
passé vous êtes satisfaite de votre sœur
oh je pense oui oui
j'aurais non je je ne vois pas ce que je
pourrais reprocher à l'existence il y en
a quand on voit autour de soi il y en a
qui sont beaucoup plus malheureux mais
il y en a aussi beaucoup qui n'essaient
pas tirer le maximum de la vie c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de faire et ce que je
continue à faire d'ailleurs vous
réussissez à tirer le maximum de la vie
je pense que oui quand on veut on
peut oui j'ai un caractère à ça
d'ailleurs vous êtes heureuse oh mais
vous me demandez qu'est-ce que c'est que
le bonheur voilà une question à vous
poser à vous est-ce que l'argent compte
beaucoup dans votre bonheur non non pas
tellement mais je pense qu'il y contribu
je devrais travailler je travaillerai je
l'ai fait d'ailleurs pensant ce que vous
pensez vous n considérez pas que vous
menez actuellement une vie bien
frivole non
pas du tout vous pensez qu'à mon âge
j'ai tout même bien le droit de
m'occuper un peu de moi-même ce sera
peut-être plus pour tellement longtemps
on ne sait jamais n'est-ce pas et ça ne
rétrécit pas terriblement les choses de
ne s'occuper que de soi-même oh je
m'occupe pas que de moi-même n'est-ce
pas je m'occupe pas que de moi-même je
m'occupe de pas mal de personnes alors
TS en temps comme j'ai des goûts
d'assembli je vais faire leur
appartement je les murs vous voyez que
je m'occupe quand même des choses que
j'aime mais je ne ferai plus des choses
que je n'aime pas pour les quelques
années qui me reste à vivre ça je ne le
veux en aucun cas et vous ne regrettez
pas que ce soit si superficiel
non on ne peut pas toujours être très
profond c'est une chose que j'estime
c'est pas possible si on doit définir
votre vie et qu'on dis c'est avant tout
une vie égoïste vous êtes d'accord
làdessus oui absolument
absolument ça oui j'ai même une voiture
d'égoïste que de places c'est ce qu'on
m'a reproché
d'ailleurs mais vous l'assumez
entièrement oui oui certainement
j'assume toujours mes responsabilités et
je paye toujours mes dettes quelle
qu'elle soit vous ne vous sentez aucune
culpabilité non
pourquoi il m'a
V tout
je me suis pas respect humain voilz la
face de mes deux mains mais je crois
bien que par ce ge
réfléchi j'ai oublié de cacher
aussi mon
petit il m'a
V toute
nu presque nu
complètement
nu
et toujours tu re du soir au matin moi
j'en ai Mar de
[Musique]
toujours c'est que pe je la
TR jusqu'à ce que
[Musique]
j'